my name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great
he's gonna be here any minute should be
simple enough give me your money so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian Spiderman
I am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
miles's grades are pretty good a and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what okay miles
win wanna get out of here
welcome to spider Society
Spider-Man oh no way all of us are
me
Miguel O'Hara he's like a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy plus he's like
such a good leader
miles there's moments in our stories
that are the same for all of us some
good did you bring our baby to another
fight I knew I was gonna regret making
her that web shooter you asked me not to
so I didn't I wouldn't it's in bed you
have a choice between saving one person
and saving every word to me that's an
obvious choice send me home I can't do
that I can do both all stations stop
Spiderman
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run sorry
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run